is innovation key to success the former
finnish prime minister kicked off the
last day of hearings by handing out the
suites
yerry katainen spoke with the confidence
of a man that has guided finland's
economy
but it wasn't all plain sailing
as minister of finance and prime
minister of finland you are one of the
strongest advocates of australia
austerity today you propose an
investment stimulus why
we have to reduce debt in order to get
growth
and we have to produce growth in order
to reduce debt you spoke of growth and
investment but it's a bit like the
chicken and the egg which comes first
ever-growing death
would endanger our economic recovery the
first there must be stability and there
we need investments
over to the arena of second chances meps
welcomed the return of the lord
hello i'm looking forward to having a
hearing
the commissioner designate for financial
affairs was called back for failing to
put flesh on the bones of his european
vision but applying the old english
logic of try and try again he'll welcome
the second calling
when i said last week that i was looking
forward to seeing you again
um
there's an old saying in english about
being careful what you wish for
and the charm offensive didn't stop
there i would like if we may
to step back a little
and ask you to imagine for a moment that
it is
2019 the big picture for 2019
europe has returned to growth
unemployment is falling
and our union by the way
remains a family of 28 member states
including the united kingdom i listened
with care to your fairy tale are you
ready at least to give some examples of
names of companies for which you lobbied
so to the reason why he was called back
concrete answers
to
the market perception in terms of the
rigor of those tests i understand has
been very positive and institutional
investors in very large numbers are
expressing their confidence in the
exercise so there we had it we're all
but done and as we bid once again due to
lord hill it's back to meps to hold
court over his and katynand
commissionership